Moving on to the next line in our code,
we see that running the newSaga () ;
function should have the effect of
creating a new execution context, so
that it can make room for new variables
that are local to that function column.
Then, the new context will become the
interpreter's new current context, for
as long as that function is running.
This first line will add a new
variable to the current scope.
The next line adds another
variable to the red scope,
this time holding a function value.
At this point, we'll have to do
a lookup on the saga variable,
In order to know which function
these parens are attempting to call.
The interpreter handles this by
checking whether the name saga
has any meaning in its current
context; the red context.
The interpreter checks the scope of
the current execution context, and
finds that the saga variable is
available locally in that red scope.
The value found there
is a function object.
And the parens next to the word saga,
tell the interpreter to
invoke that function.
Running the saga function will
build a new execution context, and
move the interpreter's
lookup focus into it.
The first line adds a new
variable to that local scope, and
now we do lookups on all
three of our variables.
Again, the interpreter will do this,
by scanning outward from its
current context, looking for
the closest containing context
that can satisfy a requested name.
First it goes looking for hero,
which can't be found in the containing
context, and so it falls through.
Falling through to the red context,
the interpreter does not find
a hero variable there either.
Finally, falling all the way
through to the global context,
the variable is found there.
The string being logged is
beginning to get built up.
Next, it goes looking for
the deed variable.
What will be the output of that lookup?